it was
great having their
support and their help and
their perspective
right and because of who they were
they were they were sort of in a no-fly
zone as far as their officer's special
affairs went
they were left pretty much alone david
miscavige
didn't want any them coming out publicly
they hadn't said anything
they were sort of getting on with their
life
and so that was a great great
environment for me and yeah
and you know i'm eternally thankful to
them
do you is there any sort of like silver
bullet or
or thought process that you can look
back on
that started off your
your thought process of your kind of
like self-reflective thought process
that helped you
escape that prison of belief was there
any sort of thing in particular you can
look back at that kind of kicked that
off
yeah the physical violence okay
i you know i would look
at that and go this is not what i got in
scientology for
this is not what i this is not my
perception of what scientology really is
and though it's rationalized and
explained away
as being you know uh
various things you know your own fault
or
you know we shouldn't be causing david
miscavige to lose his temper
or whatever it was just
um
it was so foreign to what i believed
were the fundamental principles of
scientology and then what
really set it off was
when john sweeney was doing his
reporting for panorama on the bbc
he had spoken to a lot of people
and they had told him about miscavitch
physically abusing people and
john sweeney asked me on camera
is this true and i denied it
and muscavich was talking to me on the
phone every day and telling me you know
you bet they better not come out with
any of this this is [ __ ]
this is better not air blah blah blah
blah blah
and ultimately
i went you know what am i doing why am i
lying about this
because john sweeney is saying to me
i've got
credible witnesses who each one of them
have said that they have seen david
miscavige
physically assaulting you i'm thinking
why am i lying to protect that like
i had gone on tv and i had lied about
various things like about ot3
in particular this is one of these
things in scientology
the the crazy story of xenu and the
intergalactic
confederacy confederacy etc etc yeah and
scientologists believe
that that is harmful
and can cause great spiritual harm to
anybody who has not received not
risen to that level in scientology
and i firmly believed that at the time
so i was being interviewed by katie
couric on the
today show and she's like well tell me
about xenu and you know this and then
i'm like ah
no such thing and i knew that that was
not the case but i
believed that this was
a matter of religious conviction
that i shouldn't talk about that because
it would
be hurting people to do so it would hurt
the public perception
no it would actually hurt people that
you could die
hubbard says that if you're exposed to
those materials before you are ready for
them and have
advanced through the scientology steps
proceeding that it can cause you to
to actually physically die that you can
it's a long-winded explanation but your
spirit's not ready for that kind of
enlightenment
exactly and that it will cause you to to
spin
into a an uncontrolled
he calls it freewheeling of
[Music]
flu and disease and illness and
death body death
and i believe that i was
like at the time i thought that was a
justifiable thing to
do that to not acknowledge that
was a good thing in other words
lying about that was good i'm gonna get
i'm getting to this point of
with john sweeney and i go why am i
lying about this
this just is like yes it's happening
if it really is happening and and
this is an actual part of scientology
like
and you know we're a tough outfit and
we're
getting the job done and whatever you
know all the other
sort of things that go along with it why
not just say that
why don't just admit it like yeah i'm a
tough son of a [ __ ]
but i'm getting my job done i got irs
exemption
i'm like so
there didn't seem to be a good a good
you know rationalization for that and
that was what
really like this gnawed at me and
gnawed at me and naught at me and
that's why eventually i left in london
you know that was sort of the
this last couple of weeks of my
35-year career in the sea organization
yeah were very intertwined with
john sweeney bbc panorama and what david
miscavige was saying to me
yeah obviously you talked earlier about
how you you kind of feared
the backlash from it and you understood
as being the head of special affairs
what would be the result of you leaving
and all of the negative attention and
the stalking and the harassment and all
that
um is that
the reason people like tom cruise and
john travolta haven't
come out and talked about scientology
and exposed it to the level that you
have or at all
because i remember i remember the lady
in the documentary who said she was
close to tom
or not tom john travolta thank you
spanky yeah she worked with him forever
and she was pregnant right which is this
the
same same way yes absolutely she was
thinking she was pregnant they took her
baby from her
when she was right when he was born
because she was in the rpf having a baby
was too much of a burden and it would
it would distract you from your your
goals in scientology so they took the
baby
to like a cadet ward or something i
believe it was called exactly
and she found her baby there
malnourished like her eye couldn't even
open
her eyes exactly that [ __ ]
was a brutal story so and then i can't
imagine
someone like john travolta seeing this
happen to a close friend
and just completely well john travolta
like i mean the short answer to that
question is
if the if they're not out
and exposing scientology it means
they're still true believers
and john travolta in particular has
always responded to questions
about that or other
abuses that people have asked him about
ex
you know witnessing and saying look i
don't know about any of that
i just know scientology has helped me
so i'm for scientology
and he's gotten away with that for a
long time
and you know gotten away with it i mean
that's his prerogative to say that if he
wishes
that nobody follows up and goes yeah
okay but you know isn't that pretty
irresponsible of you
like don't you think that maybe you
should be concerned about what's
happening with these other people who
you know david miscavige isn't punching
you in the face john
but what about the other people who he
is they're not like
forcing you into bankruptcy john but
what about the people who are
but you know generally the
the press goes pretty easy on
cruz and travolta when it comes to
scientology
well partly because they're afraid of
being accused of being bigots
because scientology will turn around and
you start having people going
well you know a reporter really going
after them on that
and scientology will go after the
reporter and start saying
this guy's a bigot he's uh you know he's
doing you know would he ask frank
sinatra
about his catholicism would he tell you
know
would richie gear being you know be
interrogated about his
belief in buddhism and blah blah blah
blah blah blah
and there are all these lines and so
you know reporters for the most part are
also
somewhat intimidated by scientology's
reputation
and you know there's a couple of them
who have not been
john sweeney and brian seymour in
australia have said
you know i want to ask and i will
ask tom cruise these questions so they
get banned from
any interviews so tom cruise goes on a
press junket for his next movie
mission impossible 27 or whatever it is
that's coming
yeah and brian seymour and john sweeney
are on the list of reporters who are
forbidden
to participate in the press junker
because
they only want people that will ask them
puffballs
so i don't know it's uh
you know i'd love to have a sit down
with john
or tom and leah and i have offered that
many many times we've
leah and i have tried to get any
scientologist to talk to
us either on the aftermath
now on the podcast anybody come on
let's you know let's have a discussion
yeah you can you can defend
whatever it is and and put forth your
position but they are
definitely afraid to do that they just
won't put themselves in a position where
they are having to answer difficult
questions
so they don't even have any spokespeople
anymore do you think
the reason that people like john
travolta and tom cruise
don't come out or leave scientology is
because they're afraid they have
too much dirt on them from the auditing
sessions
i don't i i don't think that because
they i know that
in the documentary again i know there's
a mention of hidden cameras in some of
those because
john didn't want cameras in his session
so they hated
cameras right well they're hidden in
every auditing room but yeah
yes that's true so you don't think
there's an i mean could there be enough
dirt to where there could be
certainly there could be you're asking
me do i think that's the case
i don't think that's the case i mean i
think you know if i was the pr person
for tom cruise or john travolta i would
tell them
look the best pi you will
ever get is to say i'm no longer a
scientologist for sure
and if scientology then comes out and
says yeah but you're [ __ ] dogs on the
side
you just go oh that's just scientology i
mean
it's easy to deal with these days
like those guys which one of them
[ __ ] dogs
those guys could just dismiss it oh or
or
you know well john travolta you're a
homosexual who
solicits men to give them [ __ ] in
bath houses right and you just go
okay so what yeah
and what if i did so what like you
you're not gonna come to my movies hey i
guarantee you there will be a lot more
people
that will not come to your movies
because you're a scientologist
right than people who will not come to
your movies because you gave someone a
[ __ ] in a bath house right
so what do you got to lose so i don't
believe that that
is why i believe they're true believers
and i believe that they are still in
that prison mind
prison of belief